cette semaine est-ce que les langues
autochtones varie beaucoup entre les
différentes nations
oui bienvenue part à l'automne si c'est
mélissa mollen dupuis cette semaine j'ai
reçu une de ces questions que j'adore
recevoir c'est à dire sur les langues
autochtones parce que de plus en plus la
présence justement du sujet des langues
autochtones dans les médias dans le
milieu politique est après de se
prononcer et de plus en plus nous
reconnaissons justement de l'importance
de protéger ces langues et même au point
de les reconnaître comme des langues
nationales avec le français et l'anglais
mais pourquoi est ce que c'est un sujet
si large et pourquoi justement il ya des
différences dans les langues c'est qu'au
canada
si on regarde la carte juste du canada
il ya douze grande famille linguistique
les familles linguistique
ça veut dire que dans cette famille là
certaines des langues vont se ressembler
mais ne peut pas du tout neuf à avoir la
même sonorité les mêmes mots et à
travers ses douze familles le au canada
on a une soixantaine de langues donc
vous pouvez imaginer
si on rajoute en plus à travers c'est
l'angle les dialectes et bien on va
aller encore plus multiplié les
sonorités les connotations les mots du
territoire au canada
ces douze familles là il ya quand même
trois grandes familles qui sont
présentes au québec
la famille est ce qu elle est hot qui
comprend les inuits la famille
algonquienne pour ne pas se tromper avec
algonquin qui fait partie de la famille
qui comprend aussi les cris les
attikameks les nous les naskapis les
malécites les migrants les abénakis ce
sont des familles qui vont avoir des
sonorités très proches mais aussi très
différente si vous entendez les deux
langues et la dernière famille au québec
c'est la famille iroquois yens et là on
va parler des mots rock et des hurons
wendat
si on regarde en deux familles très
différentes c'est à dire la famille et
ce qu'elle ait ôté la famille heineken
il ya quand même les innu et les inuit
alors un nous un linux c'est quand même
les mots qui sont semblables
parce qu'on partageait le même
territoire donc par sept par ce partage
du territoire là on avait quand même
on se fréquentait on échangeait donc
j'avais des deux modèles de cartes que
j'ai trouvé qui est excellente
j'en avais une de national geographic
qui expliquait justement ces groupes
linguistiques de ces familles mais
encore dans une grange entrait dans une
division qui est beaucoup plus des
groupes et il y en a une autre qu'une
carte interactive qui comprend les
langues mais aussi les territoires
traditionnels dans la compréhension des
langues
et ça c'est très important parce que si
on regarde juste la langue qui nous par
exemple parce que c'est ma langue
les dialectes vont changer énormément
d'une communauté à l'autre
si on regarde les innu les îles nous
mêmes au lac-saint-jean parce que
d'autres vont l'être elle en plus et
qu'on compare les mots utilisés la
prononciation des in ou de la basse côte
nord c'est extrêmement différents et
pourquoi ces différents et parce que le
territoire change le territoire voire
influencer quels mots on va utiliser
plus souvent quelques rencontres on va
faire aussi avec d'autres nations et non
seulement ça mais le territoire change
la projeter et on est tellement
important que même quand on eu la mise
en réserve la langue s'est dit que
n'ayant la langue de bourreau et la
langue de village et c'est ce qui fait
que beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui n'ont
pas accès à la langue de bois puisqu'ils
n'ont pas accès au territoire comme
leurs grands parents pouvaient le faire
autrefois donc mais l'accès au
territoire change les prononciations
changent les mots qui ont été utilisés
et c'est là un regard très important
donc la langue n'est pas uniquement une
question de groupe une question de
territoire
alors vous comprenez comment ça peut
être un sujet passionnant parce que
l'autre tu regardes je suis nous mais
l'autre comment on fait pour écrire des
textes comme on fait pour créer des
livres et bien il ya des exercices qui
se font entre nations d'uniformiser la
langue et on va trouver des
dictionnaires qui ont uniformisé
mais on veut pas non plus perdre cette
belle distinction des dialectes donc
mais c'est juste une manière de pour
travailler ensemble sur une seule langue
j'espère avoir répondu à la question
j'espère que ça vous a piqué la
curiosité d'en poser plus n'hésitez pas
à nous envoyer des questions
il n'était pas partagé le vidéo on vous
souhaite une très belle semaine de
l'apport de parole autochtone